.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Du bist dran. Willst du hüpfen?
Wir gehen von hier.
Ich halte es kaum aus, Moosi.
Komm, jetzt gehen wir. Wirklich.
Karabiner mitnehmen und aushängen.
- Karabiner mitnehmen?
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das machen soll.
Geh zuerst einen Schritt runter.
Links herum.
Ich weiss nicht,
was ich machen soll, verdammt.
Geh links auf die Ecke.
Da ist ein Knopf in etwas,
das ich gerne machen würde,
nachdem mein Herz wirklich schreit.
Je älter du wirst
und je länger du es nicht machst,
desto mehr baut sich die Angst auf.
Das ist mir passiert.
Von 34, 35, 37, 38 an
wurde es immer schwieriger.
Irgendwann fragte ich mich:
"Wieso soll ich da rauf?
Das muss man nicht."
Aber eigentlich sind die Berge da
und man kann sie besteigen.
Das ist es, was ich will.
Ich schaue die Berge nur an.
Ich kann eine Woche am Strand sitzen,
aber ich bin ein Bergler.
Schon als Kind hatte ich den Traum,
die Dufourspitze zu erklimmen -
mit 4'634 m
der höchste Berg der Schweiz.
Dieser Traum
soll Wirklichkeit werden.
Ich will mich
meiner Höhenangst stellen.
Wie viele Touren
konnten wir deswegen nicht machen?
Das ist es, was mich stört.
Fabian Mooser
ist der Bergführer meines Vertrauens.
Er hat sich dazu bereit erklärt,
mir zu helfen.
Zum Üben nimmt er mich mit
in die Gorgeschlucht.
Sie liegt oberhalb von Zermatt
und ist eine Art Kletterpark.
In diese dunkle Schlucht
geht es gleich hinunter.
Klettergurt anziehen,
Helm, Handschuhe.
Dann gehen wir zum Stahlkabel.
Sobald du eingehängt bist,
bist du safe.
Dann passiert nichts mehr.
Wirklich?- Hundertprozentig.
- Du kannst mich nicht fallen lassen?
Ich zeige dir trocken, wie es geht.
Jetzt sind wir ja noch hier.
Schau.
- Aber ich weiss, was kommt.
Warte.- Ich kriege
kaum noch einen Satz raus.
Du weisst, was kommt,
aber du hast das noch nie gemacht.
Was kommt denn?
- Krasse Höhe und abseilen.
Schaue ich runter, schaue ich
nicht runter, schaue ich hinauf?
Ich sage dir, was kommt: ein
Stahlkabel. Hier hast du Karabiner.
Du kannst dich einhängen und
bist immer gesichert. Das kommt.
Bezieh es nicht nur aufs Bergsteigen
oder auf das hier.
Das gibt es überall.
Das Restrisiko ist überall.
Das Leben ist tödlich.
Der Tod
ist das einzig Sichere im Leben.
Eines Tages wird es passieren,
aber an allen anderen Tagen nicht.
Recht hat er ja.
Du kommst hinter mir her.
Du bist mein Schatten.
Hier ist bereits das Stahlkabel,
schau.
Erste Hürde: 27 m abseilen.
Das ist alles nur im Kopf.
Das ist mir schon klar.
Warte, warte, Salar.
- Ich kann das nicht.
Lass das Seil los.
Nimm das Seil.
Geh gemütlich nach vorne.
Ich halte dich. Wenn ich zu stark
ziehe, ziehe ich dich mit.
Dreh dich um, damit du mich siehst.
- Halt mich fest.
Ich bin da. Dreh dich um.
- Fabian ...
Da ist die Stahlkonstruktion.
Du merkst: Ich halte dich, ja?
Ja, komm wir machen es einfach.
Nimm das Seil vor dir in die Finger.
Mit beiden Händen?
- Ja.
Du lässt mich nicht los?
- Ich halte dich.
Loslassen?
- Loslassen. Beide Hände.
Ich kann nicht, hältst du mich?
- Ich bin da.
Jetzt wartest du. Noch nicht gehen.
Ich zittere.
- Noch nicht gehen.
Jetzt kannst du die Beine strecken.
Schön runterlaufen.
Muss ich runterschauen?
- Nein, schau mich an.
Ich halte dich, siehst du?
- Schnell.
Ich bin da.
Gut.
Geht es?
- Ja, mach schnell.
Nicht mehr so gut.
* Angestrengtes Ächzen *
Hey, ich zittere.
Es war brutal und irgendwann ging es.
Man muss sich darauf einlassen,
damit man wirklich ...
Es ist eine Todesangst.
Man denkt: "Hält der Gurt?"
Wie war es, Salar?
- Ich habe es überlebt.
Super.
Die nächsten drei Stunden
geht es pausenlos weiter.
Auch wenn es steil ist:
Ich bin gesichert.
Jesses Gott. Also gut.
Ist gut? Gehen wir weiter? Gut.
- Wir gehen weiter.
Ziehen.
Jetzt kannst du
wieder auf das Eisen stehen.
Komm, komm!
Du kannst kommen.
Bah.
Gopferdeckel. Heilandsack.
Hey, nein! Hör ...
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Hält es?
- Ja, ja.
Es passiert nichts, oder?
- Nein. Zieh die Beine an.
Holy shit.
Mooser!
Man muss ihn
auf eine gute Bahn bringen,
damit er sieht, dass es cool ist
und nicht nur gefährlich.
Dann kommt es gut.
Er reisst sich stark zusammen.
Es ist die Höhe.
Eigentlich ist es schön.
Wenn man es geniessen könnte,
wäre es ein schöner Moment.
Ja,
das Leben hängt am seidenen Faden.
So kommt es mir vor.
* Er atmet tief ein und aus. *
Heute Abend bin ich fix und fertig
von den Nerven.
Ich schlafe miserabel.
Heute geht es nämlich an den Ort,
an dem ich vor zwei Jahren
kläglich gescheitert bin:
auf den Feechopf.
Der Aufstieg ist ein Traum.
Genau in solchen Momenten spüre ich,
warum ich das Ganze mache.
Die Berge sind meine Welt.
Das Matterhorn - hier fing alles an.
Bis ich merkte,
dass das so exponiert ist,
dass es nicht geht.
Wenn wir rübergehen,
sehen wir das Klein Matterhorn.
Dann der einfachste Viertausender
der Schweiz.
Da war ich schon mit Fabi.
Das ist das Breithorn.
Dann geht es weiter:
Castor, Pollux ...
Es ist einfach
ein wahnsinnig schönes Panorama.
Dann kommt mein Ziel:
der höchste Berg der Schweiz -
die Dufourspitze mit 4'634 m.
Man sieht das Nordend,
den weissen Spitz,
und dahinter die schöne Dufourspitze.
Bin ich immer am Seil
oder lässt du mich los?
Was mache ich?
- Du würdest mich nicht loslassen.
- Seil.- Eben.
Bist du am Seil oder nicht?
- Ich bin am Seil.- Eben.
Die Idee ist, ihn ab und zu
an seine Grenzen zu bringen,
damit es nicht nur einfach ist
und dann der Hammer kommt.
Der Plan ist, Reserve aufzubauen.
Damit es ihm hier gut geht,
und dann geht es
zur nächsten, strengeren Situation.
Das sind längere, höhere Touren,
bei denen die Luft noch dünner ist.
So hat er einfach Reserven.
Die Spur ist gut.
- Nein, nein, nein.
Salar, du schaust falsch.
Meine Füsse sind hier.
Ich kann das nicht.
- Doch, schau auf die Füsse.
So hatte ich es mir gedacht:
Es hat mehr Schnee,
es ist sehr schmal.
Der Grat zum Allalinhorn
fühlt sich noch genauso Furcht
einflössend an wie beim letzten Mal.
Da geht es noch.
Dann gehen wir hier auf die Felsen.
Ich gehe hier rüber.
Hier halte ich dich.
Schau, ich habe sogar einen Felsen,
um dich zu sichern.
Und weiter.
- Oben?- Genau.
Bleibe ich oben?- Genau.
Hey nein, Mooser, scheisse.
Nein, nichts ist scheisse.
Ich kann nicht zur Seite schauen.
- Du hast es bis hierher geschafft.
Das ist nichts.
- Komm mit dem linken Fuss hierher.
Hey, Mooser, scheisse!
- Ich bin da.
Ich will nicht,
mir ist einfach nicht wohl.
Wir sammeln uns. Sammeln.
Kannst du diesen Schritt
hier rauf machen?
Ich mache das nicht extra,
es ist einfach im Kopf.
Salar,
du musst dich nicht rechtfertigen.
Ich weiss,
dass du es nicht extra machst.
Drehen wir um?
Bis hierher war schon super.
Also, komm, wir gehen.
- Wirklich sehr gut.
Hat es vorne mehr Platz?
- Gehen wir oben durch?
Lass uns etwas gehen ...
- Komm, wir gehen einfach.
Gut.
- Gut.
Hier kannst du dich drehen.
Du kannst es dir ansehen.- Nein!
Schau.
- Ich kann nicht.
Du musst nicht schauen,
wenn du nicht kannst.
Ich weiss nicht, wie umdrehen.
- Umdrehen und sammeln oder weiter?
Umdrehen wäre gut.
Ich weiss nicht wie.
Lass mich zuerst. Ich gebe dir die
Hand, dann kannst du dich drehen.
Auf welche Seite?
- Gegen das Matterhorn.
Gib mir den Stock. Au.
- Sorry.
Gib.
Was soll ich jetzt?
- Du kannst dich drehen.
Genau so.
* Schrei *
Nein, nimm den Stock in die Finger.
Gut.
Ich bin hinter dir.
Jetzt musst du
über den Grat vorangehen.
Ist das gut?
- Ja, ich halte dich.
Langsam, ganz gemütlich.
Mach kurze Schritte.
So ist gut.
Du kannst gehen.
Langsam, bloss nicht stressen.
Ich will auf den Boden.
Eilen ist gefährlich.
Einen Schritt nach dem anderen.
Auf den Stein stehen?
- Kurze Schritte. Ja.
Hält das?
- Ich würde sagen.
Gut.
- Kann ich einen Schritt machen?
Gut. Nur nicht eilen.
Wegrennen nützt nichts,
das musst du konzentriert machen.
Gut, jetzt sind wir zurück.
Schau, da sind wir.
Wir waren dort drüben, schau.
- Woah.
Gut gemacht.
- Weiter als letztes Mal.
Shit.
- Wir kamen weiter als letztes Mal.
Man kann nicht erklären,
was passiert. Fuck.
Sing ein Lied - "Highway to Hell"
oder was auch immer.
Aber du merkst: Ich bin da.
Jeder Mensch
kann auf 20, 30 cm gehen,
aber in dieser Höhe ...
Es zieht mich in alle Richtungen.
Es ist nicht ohne,
wenn es exponiert ist.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie oft ich mich heute gefragt habe,
wieso ich das alles mache.
Nur deshalb: Ich will jeden Berg
mit meinen Skiern erobern können.
* Beschwingte Rockmusik *
Ich will noch
einen Schritt weitergehen und lernen,
meine Angst zu verstehen.
Deshalb treffe ich heute
die Angstexpertin Steffi Weidt
in der Psychiatrischen
Universitätsklinik Zürich.
Ich finde es nicht falsch, sich
mit der Psyche auseinanderzusetzen.
Bei dieser Angst
ist ja alles im Kopf.
Zu einer Fachfrau zu gehen,
ist genau das Richtige.
Manchmal hadert man
mit einem solchen Entscheid,
aber ich freue mich mega
und bin offen für diese Hilfe.
So, die Stunde der Wahrheit.
Herr Bahrampoori,
Sie hatten mir gesagt,
dass Sie eine komische Angst hätten.
Sie haben den Eindruck,
es sei etwas mehr,
als das üblicherweise der Fall ist.
Wollen Sie berichten,
was da los ist?
Ich denke das v.a., weil sie sich
schleichend aufgebaut hat.
Ich hatte die als Kind nicht.
Es geht um diese Höhenangst.
Als Kind wollte ich
immer Fallschirmspringer werden,
ich kletterte auf hohe Bäume ...
Ich hatte überhaupt keine Angst.
Früher bereitete das keine Probleme.
Da machten Sie
solche Ski- und Bergtouren.
Jein. Ich war natürlich jünger.
Ich exponierte mich in diesen Höhen
einfach auf eine andere Art.
Das störte mich überhaupt nicht.
- Okay.
Ich sehe aber auch
einen familiären Zusammenhang.
Ich habe mir in den letzten Monaten
viele Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Ich erkannte,
dass mein Vater Höhenangst hatte.
Wir waren einmal
auf einer Bergtour in Graubünden.
Da setzte er sich hin
und er war kreideweiss.
Mein Vater war ein Typ,
der mir eher sagte:
"Salar,
du musst dich nicht exponieren."
"Es muss nicht gefährlich werden."
Er war eher
auf der vorsichtigen Seite.
Vielleicht hat das einen Einfluss.
Mein Vater
ist vor rund 20 Jahren gestorben.
Ich nehme mir immer wieder zu Herzen,
was er gesagt hat,
einfach gewisse Sachen, die er mir
mit auf den Weg gegeben hat.
Mich so zu entblössen,
ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Ich bin aber froh um die Analyse
und v.a. um den Tipp,
mich der Angst bewusst auszusetzen.
Ein Teil der Therapie
umfasst das Folgende:
Man geht nicht zurück.
Man bleibt da, wo man ist.
Im allerersten Moment ...
... passiert das: mehr Angst.
Mehr Angst.
- Das  s o l l  passieren.
Das  m u s s
in einer sog. Exposition passieren.
Was passiert dann
oder was soll passieren?
Das Hirn denkt:
"Das war gar nicht so schlimm."
"Ich habe es ja geschafft."
So erkennt es immer weniger
Situationen als gefährlich
und die Angst
klingt langsam, langsam ab.
So.
Das klingt so,
als wäre das trainierbar.
Ist es auch, das ist ein Training.
Angst kann man wegtrainieren,
wenn man so will. Ja?- Ja.
Ich muss das etwas sacken lassen.
- Ein bisschen verarbeiten, genau.
Aber es ist sehr spannend
und macht total Sinn.
Ich gehe wieder auf die Berge.
Okay, machen Sie das. Viel Erfolg.
- Vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Gerne.
Mit Steffi Weidts Worten im Hinter-
kopf besteige ich die nächsten Berge.
Hier bin ich auf dem Weg
zum Weissmies,
einem der 48 Viertausender
in der Schweiz.
Du möchtest klettern lernen,
also gehen wir klettern.
Salar, bist du bei mir?
- Ja, ich bin bei dir.
So schlimm es teilweise auch ist,
gibt mir die Expositionstheorie
jetzt eine gewisse Sicherheit.
Eigentlich
solltest du fokussierter sein.
Das ist Sport.
Ja, das gehört dazu,
Zähne zusammenzubeissen.
So schön.- Schau mal zurück,
es sieht schon sehr schön aus.
Es ist ein anderer Blick
auf die Alpen. Traumhaft.
Und: Jeder Schritt ist ein weiterer
Schritt Richtung Dufourspitze.
Ich will mich noch anders exponieren:
Mithilfe von Virtual Reality
können Ängste therapiert werden.
Mein langjähriger Freund Robbie
forschte einst auf diesem Gebiet
und bot mir an,
bei ihm ein Training zu machen.
Robbie, hoi.
- Hey. Hoi.
Tschau.
- Hoi, welcome. Lieseli, hoi.
Jö.
Du bist deswegen hier.
- Ja. Ich bin enorm gespannt.
Komm rein. Wir ziehen uns das rein.
Mit Virtual Reality
können wir diese Sachen simulieren.
Wir können eine visuelle Inversion
simulieren - mit grossem Bildwinkel.
Du drehst den Kopf ...
- Kann ich alles sehen?
Wie echt. Du siehst alles.
Es fühlt sich echt an.
Wir können deine Angst
damit herauskitzeln.
Das ist die Planke,
über die du gehst.- Nein.
Der einzige Unterschied ist,
dass die Planke am Boden liegt
und wenn du danebentrittst, fällst
du in der virtuellen Welt hinunter,
aber hier nicht.
- Ah, das passiert auch?
Ja, das passiert auch.
Das wollen wir aber nicht.
Das ist nicht das Ziel, oder?
- Nein.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das meiner Angst
guttun bzw. nützen würde.
Ich muss das Brett
schnell kalibrieren.
Robbie befasste sich
schon in den 90er-Jahren
an der Uni Zürich mit Virtual Reality
und promovierte sogar darin.
* Startton *
Jetzt funktioniert es.
Ich fahre hoch.
* Lockere Musik *
* Ausatmen *
Also ...
Ich habe ganz feuchte Hände.
- Mit den Füssen auf die Planke.
Ganz langsam nach vorne.
- Nein, hey ...
Komm, Salar, das ist nicht echt.
Schau mal runter,
schau dich um.
Boah.
Noch etwas nach vorne.
Stoss mich nicht runter.
Wirklich. Ich will nicht fallen.
Du machst das gut Salar.
Spürst du den Wind?
Jesses Gott,
ich habe wirklich feuchte Hände.
Ganz schlimm.
- Versuchst du es noch einmal?
Ja, aber für mich
ist das wie eines zu viel,
weil das so schmal ist.
Es ist wirklich happig,
nicht runterzufallen.
Der Wind und die Geräusche -
das ist eindrücklich.
Den Wind habe ich dir eingestellt -
neben den Geräuschen.
Da kommt wirklich Wind?
- Ja, da kommt wirklich Wind.
Schlimm ist auch,
dass es wirklich weit oben ist.
Robbie, ich brauche wirklich
noch mal deine Hand.
Jetzt gehst du nach vorne.
Oh!
- Umdrehen geht. Komm.
Ich weiss nicht,
wieso ich so zittrig werde.
Jetzt hast du es selbst gemacht.
- Aber nicht mit einem guten Gefühl.
Boah.
Dass man sich so täuschen kann!
Ich dachte,
ich komm hierher und sage:
"Das hilft nicht.
Ich weiss, dass ich hier stehe."
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass mir das so einfährt.
Ich glaube, das hat viel gebracht.
Danke.
- Salar, komm gut nach Hause.
Danke für den Besuch.
Jederzeit wieder.
Ja, ich komme wieder, danke.
Komm, Lieseli.
Und noch ein Viertausender.
Diesmal
steht die Breithorntraverse an.
Das Schöne ist:
Ich habe gerade darüber nachgedacht,
dass die Angst
mehr oder weniger weg ist.
Ich hätte nie geglaubt,
dass man die so abbauen kann,
wenn man wirklich dranbleibt.
Einfach machen - hingehen und machen,
exponieren, exponieren.
Jetzt kann ich hier
mit Freude hinaufkommen.
Ich weiss, dass es hinter dieser Wand
1'000 m runtergeht,
aber es stresst mich nicht wirklich,
weil ich weiss,
dass wir es im Griff haben.
Dass meine Glücksgefühle
bald schwinden,
ahne ich hier noch nicht.
Wenn ich sehe, was mir bevorsteht ...
Nicht nötig. Schau auf meine Füsse.
- ... ist es nicht ganz easy.
Gut. Ja.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Gut. Tipptopp.
Pickel an den Rucksack.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Jawohl, dann kommst du zu mir.
Schritt für Schritt.
Und jetzt?
- Aufstehen. Nicht am Seil halten.
Aufstehen.
Komm noch einen Schritt.- Gut.
Nicht absteigen.
- Moosi, das ist hardcore.
Ja, ich weiss.
Ich freue mich auf den Tag,
an dem du mir etwas Neues erzählst.
Du bist dran. Willst du hüpfen?
Wir gehen von hier.
Ich halte es kaum aus, Moosi.
Komm, jetzt gehen wir. Wirklich.
Karabiner mitnehmen und aushängen.
- Karabiner mitnehmen?
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das machen soll.
Geh zuerst einen Schritt runter.
Links herum.
Ich weiss nicht,
was ich machen soll, verdammt.
Links auf die Ecke.
Du hast gesehen, wo ich war.
Da runter?- Du hast gesehen,
wo ich durchgegangen bin.
Das ist hart. Ich muss mich
darauf konzentrieren, was ist.
Wenn ich zur Seite schaue,
müsste ich abbrechen.
Ich habe schon ein paarmal
an die Rega gedacht.
Hilf mir schnell, Moosi.
Nein, ich muss dir nicht helfen.
Du kannst klettern.
Ist gut?
- Du kannst selber gehen.
Ich muss nicht jeden Schritt
korrigieren.
Wir haben Trainingstouren gemacht.
Du weisst, wie es geht.
Salar, super.
- Fabian.
Breithorntraversierung - super.
Gut gemacht.
Tipptopp. Mega.
- Es war happig, aber gut.
Und das Beste:
Mein Ziel steht direkt vor mir.
Es gibt keine bessere Aussicht
auf die Dufourspitze mit dem Nordend.
Was sagst du? Gehen wir?
- Du kannst es dir vorstellen.
Du denkst immer, es gehe nicht,
und ich denke, es gehe ...
Wir sind angeseilt.
Das wird klappen.
Also, gehen wir.
Mein Glücksgefühl ist wieder da.
Mein Kindheitstraum
soll endlich wahr werden.
Dufourspitze, wir kommen.
Das Wetter
war in letzter Zeit sehr wechselhaft.
Nun aber ist klar:
Heute Nacht fahre ich nach Zermatt.
Sehr gut.
So.
- Danke.
Hält es?
- Ja. Achtung.
Noch ein letztes Nachtessen
mit meiner Partnerin Barbara.
Es kommt mir vor
wie eine Henkersmahlzeit.
Aufgeregt?
Geht.
Angst?
- Nein.
Es war stressig, den ganzen Tag
noch Sendung bei "G&G" zu machen
und jetzt zu packen.
Aber das Wetter
ist die nächsten Tage so gut.
Chance packen.
- Ja. Guten Appetit.
Also, auf dich.
Etwas mulmig ist mir schon,
wenn ich an die Dufourspitze denke.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es eine realistische Angst ist,
dass doch blöderweise
ein Unfall passieren könnte.
Es sind schon viele Gute
irgendwo abgestürzt.
Die Fahrt, die du jetzt um 21 Uhr
nach Zermatt machst,
ist in Relation ...
- Das sagt Mooser auch immer.
Nein, es ist nicht einfach etwas,
das er sagt.
Das Risiko ist grösser,
dass du auf der Fahrt dorthin
mit dem Auto einen Unfall baust.
Vielleicht bist du jetzt müder
und gestresster,
als wenn du dort raufkletterst.
- Ich glaube, es ist natürlich,
dass du dich wohlfühlst, wenn du
pro Jahr 40'000 km Auto fährst.
Klar, weil du es dir gewohnt bist.
Aber dort
passieren mehr fahrlässige Fehler.
Ich will dir nicht Angst machen,
dort hinzufahren,
aber man muss das
in ein Verhältnis setzen.
Wenn man dort steht,
ist das sehr schwierig.
Ich weiss. Das ist die Angst.
Man verliert die Relation
und das macht ja die Angst aus.
Barbara
redet mir immer wieder ins Gewissen.
Wir leben seit drei Jahren zusammen.
Sie kennt mich gut.
Auch für sie waren die letzten Monate
mit mir nicht immer einfach.
Er ist enorm ehrgeizig
und setzt sich halt unter Druck.
Beim Sport ist es:
eine Leistung erbringen können,
Kondition aufzubauen usw.
Salar ist nicht der Geduldigste.
Wenn es nicht auf Anhieb klappt ...
... kann er die Nerven verlieren,
oder es kann sich
auf seine Laune auswirken.
Das hast du ab und zu abgekriegt.
- Ab und zu durfte ich das erleben.
Aber wenn er nach Hause kommt
und das erlebt hat,
ist er enorm glücklich.
Und ...
... daher lohnt sich das Ganze auch.
Du kannst nicht mit. Tschüss.
Viel Spass. Geniess es.
Tschüss. Ja.
Geht es?
- Ja.
Gut.
Ich melde mich, wenn ich dort bin.
Viel Spass.
- Tschau.
Tschüss.
- Geniess es.
Tschau, tschau. Mache ich.
* Entspannte Musik *
Schau mal, Sonnenbrille ...
- Gut.
... etwas zu trinken
und ein paar Riegel.
Was ist das? Eine Wollkappe?
- Von meiner Mama.
Nein, ein Schutzengel.
Von wem ist der?
- Von meiner Mama.
Ah, der Schutzengel des Riffelhorns.
Sie sagte, ich solle ihn mitnehmen.
- Tipptopp. So einen habe ich auch.
Wirklich?
- Sicher.
Gut.
- Mitnehmen.
Etwas abergläubisch
ist man dann doch.- Ja.
Vamos.
- Vamos.
Have a nice day.
- Have a nice day.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Pickel rausnehmen.
Hier kannst du wieder
mit dem Pickel.
Mit den Zacken rein?
- Ja.
So. Genau, ja.
Dann der nächste -
und wieder kurz warten.
Eins, zwei.
Siehst du den Gipfel?
Der Fels,
der gerade in die Sonne kommt,
ist der zweite Grat.
Es hat Schnee auf dem Vorgipfel.
So konzentriert wie heute
war ich während
meines ganzen Vorhabens wohl nie.
Alles, was ich gelernt habe,
stecke ich in den heutigen Tag.
Dies ist meine Chance.
Darauf habe ich hingearbeitet.
Ich will es schaffen.
Die Höhenangst ist nicht weg, aber
ich habe gelernt, damit umzugehen.
Das geht,
aber heute haben wir starken Wind.
Es ist böig
und das macht es nicht einfacher.
Jetzt wird es wieder windiger.
Aber das geht schon.
Ah, lago mio, hey.
Mir ist bewusst:
Für routinierte Bergsteiger
ist das ein harmloser Berg.
Bei gestrecktem Seil kletterst du.
Nichts anderes.- Gut.
Gut, halt still.
-Was?
Halt kurz still.
- Ja.
Ich kann fast nicht mehr.
Es ist mein oberstes Limit.
Megaschön, überwältigend,
aber es ist auch megastreng.
Hier ist es schon ziemlich exponiert.
Es geht, aber ich muss mich
einfach darauf konzentrieren.
(Kameramann) Wie weit ist es noch?
- Nicht mehr weit, oder?
Eine Viertelstunde.
- Ehrlich?
Ich glaube es fast nicht.
Salar, ehrlich. Ja, ehrlich.
Es geht immer um dasselbe:
Ehrlich, glaub es mir.
- Ich muss mich konzentrieren.
Wie komme ich durch? Festhalten?
- Da, wo ich durchgelaufen bin.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Salar, da warten, okay?
Du kannst klettern.
Der verdammte Pickel stört mich.
Einfach so weiter.
Brutal schön ist es hier.
- Nur so weiter.- Gut.
Klettern!
Salar!
Gib Gas!
Ich weiss nicht, wo durch.
- Du musst dich nirgends halten.
Links aussen ist ein Tritt.
Gut.
Aufstehen.
Warte hier.
Bist du bereit fürs Finale?
Wo ist das Finale?
- Das Finale?
Hier.
Wenn es nicht mehr höher geht,
sind wir auf dem Gipfel.
Wo ist das Kreuz?
- Da.
Wenn es nicht mehr höher geht,
sind wir auf dem Gipfel. Tipptopp.
Ich glaube es nicht, hey.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Bravo, Salar.
Der höchste Punkt der Schweiz.
Hier.
4'634 m.
Super, genial.
Super gemacht. Tipptopp.
Schau mal, der Wind ist weg.
Wir haben Sonne im Gesicht -
sensationell.
* Triumphale Musik *
Ich habe die letzten drei,
vier Monate wirklich alles gegeben.
Ich hatte Todesangst
und musste sie ausstehen.
Aber es geht,
wenn du dich damit befasst.
Ich hatte auch wirklich gute Hilfe.
Du sagtest am Anfang, du würdest mir
bei allem helfen können,
aber den Schritt am Schluss
müsse ich machen.- Ja.
Du musst bereit sein, den zu gehen.
Das wollte ich,
daher konnte ich es wohl auch.
Sonst bricht man irgendwann ab.
Egal, was für eine Angst man hat:
Das ist der Beweis, dass es geht.
Das ist nicht
der letzte Viertausender,
den ich mit Mooser mache.
Hey, das war's jetzt?
"Bahrampussy", not anymore.
- Also gut, konzentrieren.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021